et tout autre sujet maintenant nous
avons parlé d'économie de nombreux
grands groupes sont installés à saint
quentin en yvelines ils ont juste ouais
ils ont choisi de bâtir des campus des
lieux de vie pour les salariés au mode
de travail collaboratif les atouts de
ces campus sont nombreux fanny
bourdillon nous en dit plus
elle a visité le campus du crédit
agricole a appelé skypark basé à
guyancourt regarder ce sont les premiers
à avoir installé leur campus à saint
quentin en yvelines
à la fin des années 70 aujourd'hui le
campus du groupe crédit agricole
appelée skypark évolue encore un nouveau
bâtiment a été construit pour répondre à
un enjeu majeur doubler leurs effectifs
avant la fin de l'année nous sommes
d'ores et déjà à peu près de 2800
personnes regroupées sur le campus de
skate park au sein du groupe crédit
agricole
nous allons très fortement dans les mois
à venir jusqu'en septembre 2010 est
augmenté nos effectifs puisque nous
serons à peu près 5000 un petit peu
moins 1 4800 personnes qui travailleront
sur le campus skypark évidemment ça
signifie que nous avons construit des
immeubles nous en rénovant d'autres
et puis également effectivement nous
augmentons les infrastructures skate
parc regroupe désormais six immeubles
sur une surface de 11 hectares c'est
aussi 250 salles de réunions des langes
un gymnase des restaurants et depuis peu
une application smartphone qu'une
application smartphone qui permet
d'avoir des informations générales sur
la vie du campus qui permet de se
localiser à l'intérieur du campus je
suis dans un bâtiment où j'ai besoin de
chercher une salle dans un autre
bâtiment avec lequel je ne suis pas
familier
l'application vraiment mener directement
à la salle de réunion semble je sois
obligé de tourner dans les étages on l'a
trouvé les nouvelles technologies sont
au coeur de ce campus et les avantages
sont nombreux
travail collaboratif et participatif ou
encore lieu de vie agréable pour les
salariés aujourd'hui les grands groupes
copie tout des campus étudiant c'est un
campus ouvert à prenant un peu à la mode
américaine des campus américaine de la
silicon valley des grandes entreprises
parce que ici c'est si vous voulez c'est
le campus technologique du groupe crédit
agricole et ça et donc nous amenons des
nouvelles technologies le numérique nous
transforme et doit transformer
transformer également les mentalités et
le campus à cette notion là on n'est pas
des étudiants en loin de là mais on
aimerait bien avoir cette approche
ouverte dynamique eux qui change de la
banque transit traditionnels et vous
voyez nous sommes ici dans un lieu qui
s'appelle un linge
vous ne pouvez pas vous imaginer que
vous êtes dans une entreprise du cac 40
renault airbus ou boeing
de nombreuses entreprises ont adopté la
même dynamique que le crédit agricole
faisant de saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
ville de campus